6 24 in your monday morning you know the
other day we talked about the huge plan
to rebuild i-15 at tropicana well what
if it's not finished by the time we get
our own super bowl
well after the nevada department of
transportation's presentation about this
project to the clark county commission
last week
commissioner michael naft had a question
about two years worth of traffic
disruptions
and how that could throw a penalty flag
in the middle of our potential moment in
the sportline spotlight
i noticed that that timeline bleeds
right into uh the potential for a super
bowl right here
could you speak a little bit to special
events more broadly and how the
construction
schedule will consider those major
events consulting engineer
jax ostrom the design builder that we
select will be required to have
i-15 and a certain number of lanes on
tropicana and adjacent roadways open
during all the special events that we've
identified
and the super bowl ops obviously would
be one of those events
of course we first have to be awarded a
super bowl and that hasn't happened
yet we have to hope that if and when we
do get one your end zone celebrations
don't involve having to sidestep
construction cones and detour signs
buckle up drive carefully please put on
that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 at 8